a week ago at San Diego comic-con Marvel
officially released their entire phase 4
lineup not only did they reveal phase 4
but before Kevin Feige got off the stage
he revealed some movies that will be
coming to phase 5 and now right around
the corner we have a d23 coming just
next month what's up everyone it's
Warren and a lot of people are wondering
what exactly are they going to show us
at d23 next month
well thanks to some recent reports we do
have an idea of what is to come and it
does involve two phase five movies so in
this video I will talk about what d23 is
and what we can expect to see from
Marvel be sure to subscribe like the
video and comment below with your
favorite superhero or villain so you can
enter my xbox one or ps4 giveaway so a
lot of people are very hopeful that
Marvel is going to reveal a lot more
about phase 5 at d23 d23 is a three-day
Disney fan event that Disney has every
two years this is very different than
San Diego comic-con Marvel gets their
panel only on one day Saturday and they
have to share their panel with other
studios such as Lucasfilm and Pixar so
they're probably going to get roughly 30
minutes to talk about whatever it is
they want to talk about and a lot of
people are guessing and hoping that it
is going to be about phase 5 well 30
minutes isn't enough to go over a full
phase 5 reveal it took 90 minutes to go
over phase 4 but it is being reported
that Marvel will most likely talk about
a couple of films from phase 5 and these
two films that were supposed to get a
lot of details about are reportedly
black panther 2 and Captain Marvel - now
coincidentally there has been a lot of
talk and a lot of rumors going around
recently about what black panther 2
could be about and what Captain Marvel 2
could be about and again it is just a
rumor for now but people are reporting
that black panther 2 will have Namor in
it now considering the relationship
between Wakanda and Atlantis in the
comics this just makes perfect sense and
not to mention the Easter egg in
Avengers in Game the underwater
earthquake that Hakeem mentions was off
the coast of Africa
now the Russo brothers have mentioned
that this is not an Easter Egg for name
war but I've said this before and I will
say it again
the Reese or others could just be saying
this to avoid spoilers for phase 5 in
black panther 2 because why have the
underwater earthquake part in there
that's
very specific thing to have and
especially to give that to a koi and
have it off the coast of Africa so if
these reports end up being true name
work could be in black panther 2 in fact
he could be the villain of black panther
2 and Namor being in black panther 2
could open the door up to the x-men to
start appearing in future MCU films it
could even lead to in Avengers verse the
x-men but of course like I said right
now nothing is confirmed and then the
other report about Captain Marvel 2
going around is that Captain Marvel 2
will be about Secret Invasion again this
is something that makes sense for
Captain Marvel too considering how
Captain Marvel ended and thanks to
spider-man far from home we know that
there are actually Creed that are on the
earth hidden and we know that Nick Fury
is still working with the scroll could
Nick Fury still be working with the
scroll because there is a Kree secret
invasion happening it was definitely set
up for that and spider-man far from home
and in the post-credits scene in
spider-man far from home so it seems
like phase 5 could potentially introduce
two major things into the MCU name war
and Atlantis in black panther 2 which
could possibly lead to the x-men
introduction in the MCU as well Kevin
Feige has confirmed that the x-men are
on their way to the MCU at some point in
time so we know that they are going to
be coming and then a Secret Invasion but
this secret invasion will be on a
smaller scale one that will most likely
just be addressed in Captain Marvel - so
black panther 2 and Captain Marvel 2 are
the two movies from phase 5 that are
reportedly going to be talked about at
the d23 event next month
now of course Marvel could talk about
phase 4 and more in depth and they could
go on to talk a little bit more about
phase 5 as well but as of right now it
is speculated that black panther 2 and
Captain Marvel 2 are going to be the two
phase 5 movies that Marvel will be
talking about at the d23 event so let me
know what you think about the
possibility of Namor being in black
panther 2 and Captain Marvel addressing
the Secret Invasion be sure to let me
know in the comments down below and also
don't forget to comment with your
favorite superhero or villain like this
video and subscribe to my channel so you
could enter my giveaway I'm picking a
winner at 500,000 subscribers and as
always thank you all so much for
watching we'll fluff